battlefield is heading back to the
modern era with battlefield 2042
the next installment and dice's storied
first-person shooter franchise
and that's not the only big change from
the last two games in the series
the new game is putting all its chips on
multiplayer for growing a single player
campaign in favor of leaning into what
dice does best
with huge multiplayer battles and it's
raising its player cap on next gen
console's npc
from 64 to 128 dice gave gamespot a
rundown of a lot of what we can expect
from battlefield 2042 in an early
presentation
although we don't have much footage to
work with so a lot of what you're seeing
right now
is going to be from previous battlefield
games set about 20 years in the future
the new title puts you in the role of a
non-patriotic soldier
or nopat nopats are people whose
countries have collapsed
largely as a result of global turmoil
due to climate change
as governments fail and people are
displaced the world sees massive
increases in refugees
a lot of those refugees include former
soldiers and you are one of them
at the same time all the upheaval has
triggered an armed global conflict
between the u.s and russia
who are both using no pat soldiers to
fight their wars
so in battlefield 2042 you fight for one
side or the other in theaters
all over the world with the hopes that
your side will win and that you'll get a
seat at the international table
once the dust settles you're fighting
for one side or the other but there's
potential that the no pats will work to
advance
their own agenda all that to say that
while this is a multiplayer only
live service game battlefield 2042 will
also have an evolving story according to
dice
we don't know exactly how that story
will unfold but it will be told
somehow through the 10 starting operator
characters you play in multiplayer
we saw four of those operators during
our presentation and dice says more are
coming once the game is out with the
potential to bring more narrative to the
game
at the same time operators are fully
voiced
and they're both similar to and
different from the battlefield classes
players are used to
the franchise's usual classes still sort
of exist
but they're more like categories in
which the operators
operate many operators have unique
gadgets and traits
that fall into class categories like
support engineer
recon and assault but most weapons and
other types of gadgets
are no longer class specific casper a
recon character
has a motion sensor that tells him when
someone is approaching his position
meanwhile webster is an agile assault
character who gets a grappling gun so he
can change
positions quickly and moves faster while
aiming maria a support character
has a pistol that can shoot cirrets to
heal and revive players at a distance
she can also revive teammates to full
health unlike other players who revive
their teammates with only a portion of
their health back
finally boris an engineer can lay down
turrets to help him fight which also get
a bonus if he stays near them
as mentioned you'll play operators who
fit into certain classes and have their
own pros and cons but they're not
limited in terms of what guns and
explosives they could use
so you're not locked into a particular
loadout when you take on a certain
class that should provide players a lot
of versatility to adjust their operator
to go with their play styles
there's also a new menu for adjusting
your weapon loadouts mid-game which dice
calls
the plus system it creates a holographic
interface on your gun
in the shape of a plus that lets you
quickly switch weapon attachments on the
fly
so if you're going into a close quarters
fight you can quickly add a close range
scope
a suppressor and an under barrel shotgun
and then flip to longer range
attachments as you head to a different
engagement
dice mostly focused on one part of its
multiplayer offering in its presentation
all-out warfare where two huge teams
fight for a map
this is an evolution of conquest and
breakthrough modes in other battlefield
games
each map is divided into sectors that
you're trying to capture but unlike in
past games
each sector can contain multiple
objectives to grab before you can start
scoring points against the other team
in conquest you're trying to take as
many sectors as you can
while in breakthrough one team attacks
to capture sectors while the other team
defends them making every battle a
frontline fight
map sizes vary but they're generally
bigger than what we've seen in other
battlefield games to accommodate the
increased player count
but dice doesn't want you running across
huge open fields only to get sniped
before you ever see any action
so instead each map essentially contains
a lot of smaller maps
areas where players have to congregate
and where you'll find yourself
in different kinds of battles dice calls
this approach blustering
and it's where you'll get some use out
of the plus system one objective area
might be close quarters with lots of
buildings and interiors
another might be a wide open space like
a stadium still another
might be best suited for vehicles the
idea is you'll be able to pick what kind
of fight you want to get into
as you head into the battlefield and
adjust your guns to match
you'll also have better options for
getting around those larger maps
every player will have a tablet that
lets them call in vehicles wherever they
are
so if you're far from the battle you
won't have to hoof it all the way back
to the fight
vehicles get parachuted to the spot
where you call them which means you can
potentially drop them on snipers and
other opponents
and dice has tweaked them to be more
inviting for squads you won't be just
riding along when you hop into a
helicopter
or tank because all vehicles have seats
with more to do like firing extra guns
or spotting enemies
the idea is that even when you're not
driving a vehicle for your squad
you're still an essential part of the
fight battlefield 2042
is a multiplayer focused game but that
doesn't mean you have to play
with other people dice knows that you
don't always want to jump into a sweaty
online match
which is why you can also play its
multiplayer modes alone with ai bots in
place of other players
it will be a good way to learn the maps
and the ropes of multiplayer to jump
into a battle that's a bit of a
different speed from online play
or to take on a fight that has lower
stakes with a group of friends on your
squad
dice also gave a preview of 7
battlefield 2042 maps
each set in a different place around the
globe and sporting a variety of sizes
and features
kaleidoscope is set in a south korean
city center with skyscrapers flanking a
lower area with an information hub
teams will fight over in manifest in
singapore
you'll fight through a container yard
that's essential to american supply
lines
the containers funnel players into tight
spaces for potential ambushes
but automated cranes also move
containers around to reconfigure the
battlefield
and there are anchored ships to fight
through too orbital is a medium-sized
map that takes you to french guiana
where both teams fight over a rocket
launch pad and its surrounding
structures
the rocket can launch and it can go very
badly
the next map is discarded set in india
where teams fight over a rogue nuclear
asset
changing water levels have left a bunch
of huge ships beached and rusting
so you'll fight through the hulking
wrecks renewal is an agriculture
research station in egypt that teams are
trying to capture
the entire map is divided by a huge wall
on one side is rich greenery from the
farming station and on the other
open desert you'll head to dubai for
hourglass
a huge desert map that includes a
skyscraper filled downtown area
a giant open stadium and rolling sand
dunes between the two
where vehicles can have it out and
finally there's breakaway
the biggest map in the game at almost
six kilometers across
set in antarctica players fight for oil
and gas
on a huge map that includes facilities
open ice fields
and exploding silos dice says that many
of these maps will feature its
levolution system where they can change
based on destructive elements from
players
and things happening on them like a
disastrous rocket launch
the developer also showed off severe
weather that can totally change maps
like huge sandstorms that massively cut
visibility on hourglass
an enormous tornadoes rampaging through
its urban maps that can throw
players and vehicles while most of these
details are about the current gen
versions of the game
there also will be playstation 4 and
xbox one versions
they won't be quite as impressive though
dice says they'll only support 64 player
matches
and the maps will be adjusted to
accommodate the lower player count
as mentioned this new battlefield will
also be a live service game
and dice says it'll use a battle pass
system post launch
with free and paid tracks the game has
four seasons planned already
each with a new operator they'll also
add new locations and other new content
to the game
while advancing the overall narrative
but all new maps
will be free dice has more to show off
for battlefield including two other
brands of multiplayer experience
the first is hazard zone which we only
know is a squad focused experience
that dice says is totally new to
battlefield we don't know exactly what
hazard zone is yet
but we know it's not battle royale dice
says
there won't be a battle royale mode in
the game at launch
but more info on both of those
experiences is on the way
battlefield 2042 is set to release on
october 22nd
for ps4 ps5 xbox one xbox series x and s
and pc tune in to gamespot for even more
battlefield 2042 coverage
as well as all sorts of new stuff coming
in from e3
2021 and play for all this month thanks
for watching
you